spring break but instead of fun in the
sun later this week some kids across the
valley home recovering from the flu this
is a later than normal flu season we
connect with a local pediatrician to
find out what type of symptoms warrant a
trip to the er as opposed to just a
visit to your doctor
the flu has hit southern nevada we have
a lot of kids coming down prior to
spring break mind you with influenza a
doctor carrie weejay sinha of siena
pediatrics in henderson says the strain
is hitting her office hard in just one
day her practice treated 20 kids for the
flu a lot of them are having high fevers
like 102 104
a lot of runny noses cough
very wet cough
to sore throats body aches help us that
tips us off to test
and some headaches the flu typically
peaks in december january and february
but we're in mid-april which is the
result of what dr weijie sinha calls
another ripple effect of the pandemic
where certain viruses have been pushed
you know into a kind of different
timeline and we're all hopeful that
it'll reset at some point while
pediatricians are really good at
handling the basics for flu treatment
ear infections sending kids out for
chest x-rays or doing breathing
treatments for kids with asthma dr
weijay singha says rush on over to the
emergency room if your child exhibits
the following having a hard time
breathing
god forbid turning blue
fevers that are not controlled with the
proper doses of motrin and tylenol and
again that's uh depending on the age of
the child
that would maybe warrant a visit to the
er even in the middle of the night
another thing to be cautious of there
are secondary infections that can start
after you've been diagnosed with the flu
those ear infections we talked about and
pneumonia so she says this is not
something you want to take lightly